[Musique]
un nouveau délai cette semaine pour la
mission Artemis 1 qui a déjà été
reportée à deux reprises pour des
problèmes techniques cette fois ces
passages de l'ouragan Yann qui a forcé
la NASA à ramener sa fusée à l'abri dans
un immense bâtiment en attendant sa
prochaine occasion de se lancer vers la
Lune
la mission Artemis 1 sera le premier pas
d'un programme ambitieux pour
reconquérir la lune
ce sera un vol d'essai à la fois pour la
fusée SLS qui est la plus puissante
jamais construite mais aussi pour le
vaisseau Orient qui va transporter les
prochains astronautes vers la Lune
dans la mission Artémis 2 des
astronautes vont faire le tour de la
Lune sans se poser à bord il y aura un
Canadien qui n'a pas encore été choisi
les êtres humains sont capables à dans
la courte liste des candidats il y a mon
invité David Saint-Jacques comment
regarder la lune et vous dites je
pourrais aller là moi qu'est-ce que ça
vous fait la lune c'est quand même un
rêve de beaucoup de gens
de beaucoup l'astronautes mais quand
j'étais à bord de la station puis
j'avais juste à la coupole je regardais
la terre des fois on voit la lune aussi
puis des fois je me dis ah je pense
qu'on pourrait pas tourner la station et
puis aller faire un tour ça marche pas
comme ça évidemment non ça serait
formidable
le Canada à son siège réservé à bord
grâce à sa participation à une future
station autour de la Lune le Gateway qui
fera partie du programme Artémis
dans la troisième mission
les astronautes dont une femme une
personne de couleur vont se poser au
pôle Sud ou en mille sur la présence
d'où je l'ai et dans les suivantes on
vise à construire une base sur la lune
et à extraire des ressources
mais d'ici là il reste encore beaucoup
de choses à tester
puisque l'humanité est allée sur la Lune
il y a plus de 50 ans pourquoi est-ce un
défi d'y retourner
Apollo en faisait tout pour la première
fois après des risques énormes ça a bien
marché mais beaucoup de mission qui sont
pas ses proches avec Artemis on a
l'ambition de retourner sur la Lune pour
y rester pour tester aussi nos capacités
à survivre dans son environnement là
pour un jour avoir le courage d'envoyer
des gens sur Mars qui mille fois plus
loin que la Lune
la fusée du programme Artemis utilise
les mêmes technologies que celles qui
propulsaient les navettes
mais dans une version plus puissante que
les saturnes 5 des missions Apollo
la capsule Orion ressemble à celle des
missions Apollo mais avec quatre places
au lieu de 3
pour le premier vol il n'y aura personne
à bord
c'est plus qu'un vol d'essai
certification de tout le système de la
rampe de lancement de la fusée de la
capsule de tous les équipements au sol
de toutes les équipements pour retrouver
les capsules quand ils reviennent alors
on pousse la machine au-delà de ce qui
va être exigé d'elle pendant les vols
d'utilisation
pour Artemis 1 on teste notamment la
capacité à faire des manœuvres complexes
à différents moments le vaisseau doit se
propulser pour changer de Cape autour de
la Lune
s'installer sur une orbite que la NASA
n'a encore jamais testé puis rentrez sur
terre
pour les équipes au sol c'est l'occasion
de répéter chacune des étapes et de
récolter des données sur la navigation
donc c'est un peu pour se rassurer que
le système de lancement est capable de
se rendre dans ces orbites-là la marge
le niveau de contrôle requier
et si fondamental en vue d'Artémis 3 où
les astronautes vont se poser sur la
Lune
le vaisseau Orion devra s'installer dans
une orbite différente autour des pôles
pour rejoindre le module qui permet
d'alunir c'est un plan de vol qui donne
accès à toute la surface de la Lune et
en particulier au pôle Sud
c'est en revenant de la lune quand a
lieu le test le plus important pour
Artémis 1
celui du bouclier thermique
en approchant de la terre la capsule va
se détacher du module de service et
foncez dans l'atmosphère
le choc est tel que les molécules de
l'atmosphère se disent
l'air se transforme en plasma la capsule
en étoile filante
son bouclier thermique doit encaisser
2800 degrés Celsius
c'est la seule façon de le tester en
conditions réelles
en comparaison un retour de la station
spatiale en orbite et plus là donc c'est
désormais complètement différent parce
qu'on est plus près de la terre quand on
revient de la lune on tombe de très très
loin on arrive très vite sur terre et la
trajectoire de cette mission là c'est
une ligne droite depuis la lune jusqu'à
l'atmosphère ils vont arriver à une
vitesse
d'équivalent à peu près 11 kilomètres
par seconde et ça c'est possible sur
Terre à tester ça on le tester là avec
avec des torches à plasma mais bon c'est
l'équivalent sur Terre on peut pas il
faut vraiment tester pour vrai assez
vite là ça c'est un des techniquement
c'est un des objectifs les plus
importants évidemment pour les
astronautes c'est important de savoir
que et cette partie là fonctionne bien
oui parce que vous vous avez déjà essayé
d'abord
de la Station spatiale internationale
c'est impressionnant un retour sur terre
comme ça et je dirais même que c'est une
partie du voyage spatial qui est le plus
étonnante parce que on simule pas
beaucoup on se pratique pas beaucoup au
retour parce que parce qu'on fait pas
grand chose on tombe du ciel juste
tomber de très très haut très très vite
donc le soyius fonctionne comme capsule
Orion on va le faire c'est à dire qu'il
y a une couche en fond d'époxy plus ou
moins un autre version là mais un
matériau semblable qui on a calculé près
ce qui va brûler
à mesure qu'on rentre dans l'atmosphère
il devrait en avoir assez épais pour que
on est ralenti à une vitesse raisonnable
pour pouvoir ouvrir des parachutes et
finir le retour sur terre comme ça la
technique de d'entrer dans l'atmosphère
est un peu particulière elle n'a jamais
été testé c'est le rebond sur
l'atmosphère ce qui va faire c'est
qu'ils vont frôler un peu l'atmosphère
un angle un petit peu trop aigu
ça va les ralentir mais ils vont
rebondir un peu comme une pierre qui
fait un ricochet sur l'eau et ce n'est
qu'à la deuxième
recontacte avec atmosphère que là ils
vont vraiment
piquer du nez si on veut et faire le
gros durant ça va permettre de se
débarrasser un peu de cette énergie
cinétique énorme qu'ils ont donc deux
passions c'est assez particulier c'était
les gants je trouve bien de l'essayer
une première fois sans équipage
effectivement c'est des il y a pas
beaucoup de marges d'erreur là-dedans
parce que si on arrive à un angle trop
trop aigu
et on repart ça c'est pas le fun si on
arrive trop à pics là c'est trop chaud
on ralentit trop violemment et là c'est
l'intégrité de la capsule est remise en
question donc il y a peu près c'est des
fenêtres un ou deux degrés là la
précision de l'angle
pour les équipes qui sont entraînées à
repêcher la capsule la priorité c'est de
récupérer les données enregistrées à
bord
[Musique]
la NASA estime que le risque de perdre
la capsule Orion en cours de mission à 1
sur 125
l'objectif d'Artémis 1 c'est avant tout
de réduire les risques et de détecter
s'il y a des anomalies à corriger en vue
des missions habitées
et quand il y aura des humains à bord un
défi s'ajoute les radiations
sur Terre on est exposé à des niveaux de
radiation très faibles
mais c'est assez pour soulever des
inquiétudes en particulier pour les
femmes
sur Terre on sait déjà inquiet certaines
formes de cancers qui sont plus
fréquents chez les femmes que chez les
hommes comme une sensibilité à l'effac
des radiations qui est observée dans
l'espace c'est pas les mêmes radiations
donc c'est un peu une inconnue
dans l'espace il y a à la fois des
rayons cosmiques et des particules
chargées projetées lors des tempêtes
solaires
la terre à différents protections
d'abord son atmosphère puis les
ceintures de Van Halen l'équivalent d'un
bouclier magnétique qui fait dévier une
partie des radiations
dans la station spatiale internationale
les astronautes sont donc plus exposés
que sur la terre
un chemin vers la lune ils sont à la
merci des éléments
pour la mission Artémis 1 la capsule
contient deux mannequins féminins
remplis de capteurs
l'un d'eux est équipé d'une veste pour
tenter de le protéger
le vaisseau est rempli leur expérience
comme ça pour mesurer l'environnement de
radiation dans cette dans l'espace
lointain à l'extérieur des protection de
champ magnétique et voir l'impact sur
des tissus vivants ou des trucs
apparentés au dessus du vent ça ça va
vraiment être utile pour mieux
quantifier le risque que courent
l'équipage et à quel point il faut les
protéger alors peut-être des vestes bien
positionnées pour protéger les organes
les plus sensibles peut-être aussi il y
a des plans pour faire une espèce de
refuge à l'intérieur dans lequel on
pourrait se cacher en mettant tout le
cargo autour bien positionné faire un
cocon donc c'est une alerte que pour les
radiations augmentent l'équipage
pourrait aller se cacher on devait un
peu la même chose dans la station va
coucher était un peu mieux que le reste
de la station en terme de protection
donc s'il y avait beaucoup de tempêtes
solaires beaucoup de radiations on avait
se réfugier le temps que ça tant que ça
passe
sur la Station spatiale internationale
les séjours comme celui de David
Saint-Jacques dure environ 6 mois
pour une mission vers Mars on parle de
plusieurs années d'exposition dont on
ignore les impacts
c'est vraiment un des mystères qui reste
on sait comment aller sur la Lune le
côté la propulsion la navigation la
communication on a une bonne idée mais
faire survivre des êtres humains si loin
de la terre pour aller sur la lune pour
y rester avec tout ça éventuellement le
rêve d'aller sur Mars il y a plein
d'inconnues encore là
comme dans bien des missions le succès
va aussi dépendre des astronautes qui
seront choisis autant pour leurs
compétences techniques leur tempérament
que la complémentarité entre les membres
faut que l'équipage survive il faut que
le véhicule spatial survive il faut
qu'on accomplisse l'émission ces trois
choses là
donc on trouvait l'équipage qu'il faut
pour maximiser les chances de succès de
la mission et chaque mission est
différente ça c'en est une de demander
beaucoup de sang-froid je pense à
l'équipage et puis beaucoup de beaucoup
de connaissances très intimes du
vaisseau spatial des systèmes parce que
il y a un problème et qui doivent faire
partie de la solution même merci
beaucoup David c'est Jacques